This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey, welcome to season 4 episode
17 of Chris cast.
My name is Chris Abraham and the
actual name of this podcast is
now the Chris Abraham show but
after four, three or four
seasons kind of got programmed
into it, I'm going to do State
of the Union talking about
myself, talking about what's
going on with me and talking
about some really interesting
stuff. that has recently
happened with my cardiologist,
and with my rowing machine and
with Generally the next step in
my life.
So tldr top of the top of the
list is that I went to the
cardiologist and everything's
great except my weight, I am my
heart is in sinus rhythm.
I'm not having any afib attacks.
My sugars and so forth are not
the best.
So, because I'm when I was
recently, I was 350 pounds, if
six-foot-three.
But when I went to the doctor, I
was 340 pounds and we decided it
was really important to go
radical now.
One of the radical measures
could be taking a, an injection
that would suppress my appetite,
and also work to suppress blood
sugar and issues like that.
The other thing that we talked
about at the office, not on the
phone later, was doing something
extreme in terms of diet, to
shake my Biome, to shake my
shake up my, my gut biology to
remove, all the things that I
eat that.
Bring inflammation to my body,
to try to weed out the things
I'm allergic to, or respond
badly to the things that make me
Me phlegm and all that other
kind of stuff and we decided
that we would go carnivore diet
for the next three months.
Which if you look it up is
really only water.
Black coffee bone broth black
tea, green tea, the other types
of things like ginger and all
the other types of teas as long
as there, aren't any sweeteners
in them or any milks in them.
Then beef chicken butter is
okay.
Not at all vegetable oil or
olive oil or anything else like
that.
So when I come back, I'm going
to talk more about it will.
We'll see the thing about it is
that it has as much to do with,
making sure you maximize fat fat
intake, as you do, maximize
protein and minimize car.
It's a zero carb diet, so, so
it's not the kind of thing.
Carnivore diet cannot be the
result of eating a bunch of lean
meat, you know, like chicken
breast.
And so Both.
So it's not a high protein diet,
it's a high fat moderate
protein, diet will talk more
about it afterwards.
We'll also talk About my walking
we'll talk about my rowing and
we'll talk about all that other
fun stuff.
Okay, thank you.
Welcome back.
This is Chris Abraham.
This is the Chris Abraham show
formerly known as Chris cast.
Let me know if you like Chris
Abraham show rather than Chris
cast.
It easier for people to find me
on social media and on search.
So why not that?
It was easy to do.
So, I have three months to get
back into a modicum of
trajectory towards losing
weight.
Wait and the for me, my ideal
weight is 100 kg, which is about
220. 221 pounds US.
So, the process to do it is to
follow this Carnot carnivore
diet, and with the associated
need to make sure I drink enough
water.
Plenty, plenty of water also,
Make sure that I get enough
electrolytes, because as
anybody, who knows, or is done
the keto diet or what, not the
keto flu is a real thing.
It can really bring you down.
And also to make sure that my
system remains regular and all
that other fun stuff, so, We'll
see what happens.
I have three months to do it.
I joke with my cardiologist dr.
Lux, I joke with him about how
he chose the perfect time, which
is the time during which all the
celebrations happen, you know,
Thanksgiving New Year's
Christmas etc, etc.
And you know people have their
parties and there's even
Halloween.
Queen and all that stuff.
Nothing but meat water, coffee,
tea butter and when it comes to
the meet, you need to find as oh
and sometimes they want you to
have something like liverwurst
or, or organ meat.
And so, the way that's been
looking recently, the last fewer
few days is it just seems to be
that I eat a lot of 80% lean,
I'd like 73 percent lean but 80%
lean ground beef eggs, whole
eggs, like fried and lots and
lots of butter to up the fat
content.
And then black coffee, lots of
water.
When I wake up, lots of water
all day lots of water before I
go to sleep the app I'm using
recommends, 155 ounces which is
I think over a gallon of water
but someone I just talked to in
the in the carnivore diet says
that that much water is mostly
for people who have a lot of
carbs but I'm told that That
because there's so little water
in meat that you need more water
because vegetables and so forth.
Have a lot of water in them.
So this is a winging, it kind of
diet.
Nobody knows what they're on
about, but I feel pretty good on
it.
I I try to intermittent fast 20
of 24 daily hours.
So I make sure that I eat all my
fatty meat within a 24-hour
window.
I plan to diversify from just, I
tried to buy steak but
apparently, I just bought junk,
you know, like I bought stuff
that should be stood, so I'm
going to try to go ahead and
stew and I'm going to make sure
that I use bone broth and to
make sure that you know like
just all the right things now in
addition to that he wants me to
my doctor dr.
Lux he wants me to also focus on
Fitness, right?
So you know that I'm obsessed
with doing lots and lots and
lots of walking, but what I'm
instigated and I've been telling
you, I'm about to do this every
day, but I'm actually going to
do it everyday, which is I Need
to mandatory, spend an hour on
my concept to model C.
Rowing machine every day for the
rest of my life.
Now I'm not talking about going
in and doing you know a 42 km
Marathon or anything like that.
I'm talking.
You know, I I talk a lot about
slow, jogging slow-walking, this
would be, this is slow rowing
and I started up a subreddit on
Reddit called slow.
Rowing it's reddit.com slash are
slash slow rowing and basically
it's slow.
Like yesterday, I only spent
half an hour, but I really want
to spend an entire hour every
day for the rest of my life.
Watching TV watching, listening
to podcast, listening to
audiobooks listening, to the big
broadcast watching TV, watching
movies Etc.
And what I've been doing and
this is what I consider.
Slow jogging is averaging around
a three minutes per 500 meters
which is wicked slow.
Like when I was on the crew team
and I did Sprint, like we were
easily easy at a minute, 80 a
minute 70 like per every 500
meters.
So the pace is like When 50, I
don't know, like I was the
fastest on the team because I'm
just big and strong.
I'm not light.
You can have, you can have two
of the three.
Like they say, you can have big
strong but not light.
You can have light strong, but
not big.
You can have big and light, but
not strong.
See how that goes.
So, so yeah, 23 24, 22.
Strokes per minute.
And you know, three minutes per
500 meters, which is extremely
extremely just like Like la di
da la di da like at that rate,
my heart rate never goes above
100, 110 something like that.
Like it's really just I talk
about it on a post I made which
is to say that two of the most
are three of the most valuable
things about slow.
Rowing for the rest of your
life.
Every day is that you can always
decide to do a Power 10 or a
power 20.
You can always decide to do an
Higher high intensity, workout
on the urgh.
But if you don't, if you spend
60 45 to 60 minutes, just going
like row row, row, your boat.
Like, basically, if you were in
your street clothes, in Central
Park and you wanted to take your
girl out for a rowboat ride,
like you don't want to power out
there, you want to gently, you
know, Duke Duke Jook Jook.
You don't want to get sweaty on
her, you want to be able to talk
poetry with her and and sweet
talker and smile at her and
listen to her.
And so rowing is just your
secondary activity.
That's what I'm talking about.
So what are the benefits?
The benefits, are you get a full
body compression and extension?
You go from huddled up with your
head, almost too.
Knees and your ankles almost to
your buttocks and your arms
fully extended to the at the
catch and then you, you know,
pull out to the to the finish
and your legs are extended.
Your arms are contracted, your
shoulders are, are your
shoulders are contracted, your
back, gets a stretch, your your
glutes, get a stretch, you
breathe.
With and you also you know, kind
of pump are you know what is it?
They call it push out the bad
air and with the good out with
the bad air in with the good if
you Ro you naturally, get into
that rhythm of almost walking
Buddhism.
Walking meditation.
And you know at that point your
your blood flows, your your
blood gets oxygenated oxygen
goes to your brain.
Oxygen goes through your gut
oxygen.
Oxygenated blood goes to your
limbs, your quads get, worked
out your hammies, get worked out
your calves, get worked out,
your shins get, worked out your
glutes.
Your entire interior is that
right?
Anterior.
Chain gets worked out even if
you doing it slowly, it's very
similar to the way a
physiologist.
If you have a torn ACL, Works
your knee with the machine or a
physiotherapist, does it?
That is what you be doing every
day.
You'll be doing physical
therapy, range of moment
movement.
You know, I'm on a CPAP all
night, a BiPAP.
So I have a machine that breeds
for me, but I bet you an hour on
the, on the rowing machine would
drive in breath and drive out
breath and increase.
Oxygen has 8, oxygen is oxygen,
has 8.
Oxygen is oxygen ization.
Like you wouldn't believe, so, I
do not want to while I'm getting
used to this diet.
I don't want to exert myself too
much.
So I think that even trying to
do really casual rowing for an
hour after not having done it
all summer, and all spring is
still tiring for me, you know
what I mean?
I'll admit it to you.
I'm not, when I get tired, I
stop.
If I feel better, I jump on
again and finish another In 20
minutes.
But my goal is in the short-term
to do a consistent steady state,
To 52 minutes, 50 seconds to
three minutes per 500 M slow row
every day and I'm committing to
a to I'm actually you'll find
this funny.
I'm making a stamp like
literally an ink stamp that has
on it.
It has.
It has a date type distance
time, Pace, cows HR, and notes.
And I'm going to stamp that into
every page of a rowing log that
I ordered from Moleskine which
is like what five inches by
eight point, nine inches or 5
inches by eight.
I got one that was squared and
customized to be like, you know,
Have my name Abraham and then
rollag one, or our group or a
loved one or something like
that.
And I'm going to stamp each page
with that.
And I'm going to fill it out. 11
exercise per page and what I'd
like to do because I'm so
fascinated.
What by the book, slow jogging
is this concept that if you
choose a number of minutes
during which Which to exercise.
Like, if you do it for 60
Minutes every day, you'll be
able to see over time, if you
start becoming more efficient
with your engine.
And if over time an hour equals
nine thousand five hundred
meters, or 10,000 meters, and
then in a year an hour gets you
12,000 meters or 15,000 meters.
20,000 meters, who knows?
Because like when I say slow,
rowing or slow jogging, the
secret of the whole thing is
that, as you become more
efficient, as your body becomes
more efficient, as your heart,
your VO2 max, your breathing,
your blood, your muscles, your
efficiency, as you become
stronger and stronger.
The same amount of effort will
move the boat will move.
Your urgh will move your body
will move.
You're walking remove
everything, much faster, you'll
have more of a spring to your
step.
The moment you become a
customized to it and you will
naturally feel without you even
realizing it that as casual
Errol, that you would done
before is actually much faster.
You know, like I know I'm
saying, three-minute Maya a
three-minute 500 meters but the
truth is is that generally most
people who are rowing slow Whoa,
are rolling a lot quicker than
that, but as your body adapts
you move forward.
So that's my update.
I feel pretty good on the
carnivore diet.
What really, what, what I notice
is that You really get full in
kind of an uncomfortable way
that never happened when I was,
you know, eating beans or rice
rice and beans.
Like I can eat those all day
long and never get really full,
but you put some burger and eggs
and butter and me and all of a
sudden like, like I feel like my
stomach is halfway in my throat.
So maybe that's what overeating
feels like when you feel it, or
maybe.
My cardiologist dr.
Lux said that is probably one
step further than since atea T,
then being satiated and which
is, you know, a few bites too
far anyway.
I'll come back and I don't know
what I missed, but hopefully we
can keep his continuing top-line
notes.
I haven't gotten to a straight
through 60 minutes a day.
Yet they say That the journal is
going to get here in October 5th
and I should have my stamp ready
by then.
So in my head, October the 5th
or October, the first today is
the 26th.
I'm aiming at making October the
first the first day where I do a
guaranteed 60 Minutes of slow,
rowing every day and that that's
on top of any walking or
anything else like that.
Like no, it's not.
Not either walking or rowing,
it's anything else during the
day like walking or
perambulating or slow jogging or
be on the treadmill.
Like when it gets to 6 p.m.
I have to be on the ERG to watch
my shows.
So there we are.
I'll come back to you in a
second and we'll go through how
to contact me.
Welcome back to season 4 episode
17 of the Chris Abraham show.
You can reach me at
chris@hildebrandlaw.com.
You can reach me at Chris
Abraham.com.
You can reach me at plus 1, 20
to 35 to 50 51 that can be a
phone call which I won't answer.
That can be a text, I probably
won't respond to unless you
describe exactly Actly.
Who you are and what you want.
You can't just be like Plaza.
It can work for WhatsApp signal.
Telegram, you can find me there.
I'm Chris Dash Abraham at
Tumblr.
I am twitter.com slash Chris
Abraham, youtube.com youtube.com
slash Chris Abraham linkedin.com
in /, Chris Abraham
instagram.com, Chris Abraham
facebook.com slash Chris
Abraham, what else?
If you want to figure out where
this podcast is uploaded, it's
uploaded to Anchor.com.
Press Abraham, here comes a
fighter jet.
I live in Arlington.
Virginia about a mile away from
the Pentagon and half a mile
quarter mile away from the The
national cemetery and often
times, they will do flybys for
very special people who are two
dying or being buried at the
National Memorial.
So, National Memorial Cemetery
so you know, we'll see what
happens.
Either that or it's a North
Korean bomb and we're very
quickly going to be turned into
complete Nutter.
Into dust.
All right, I think that's it
merci.
Beaucoup, gracias.
Gracias, gracias, gracias.
And Reba dirty.
I'll talk to you guys soon.
Love you.
Bye bye.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.